meine Damen und Herren wir kommen zu
unserer neuen Folge von WWM wer weiß
mehr unser heutiger Gast niemand
geringeres als Alex hallo als Alexi bexi
sensationell und wie immer dreht sich
unser Quiz um ein Spezialthema und heute
ist es Alexi bexi ich oh du
oh so ich hoffe du bist einigermaßen
vorbereitet ja natürlich
ich weiß es nicht manchmal muss man sich
einfach Einlesen in so ein Thema ich
weiß nicht wie es bei dir ist ja absolut
einlesen ist immer gut vor all auch mit
Buchstaben und Augen macht Sinn gut wie
viel Buchstaben hat er nein vergessen
wir das Wiech der Name nein wir haben
wieder sauschwierige Fragen ja und ich
würde mal sagenon wir fangen
an wie viel nein
egal welche songübersetzung wird als
erstes angezeigt wenn man nach Alexi
bexi googelt a t Cru Dynamite B Emin
featuring Rihanna love the way you lie C
Bruno Mars just the way you are oder D
Katy Perry Teenage
Dream wie wie viel Zeit habe ich um das
zu Anworten mal gucken das ist wir haben
eigentlich gar nicht so eine Zeit dann
ich erstm Kaffe nein bitte nicht also
ich hätte
gesagt schon dass es Dynamite ist also
du würdest a ja a würdest du einlocken
ja obwohl ich würde also nicht ganz
sicher aber ich glaube eher in die
Richtung tendieren ja kein Joker wir hab
den Kapitäns Joker du kannst jeden
Kapitän der hier anlegt Fragen gut habe
ich große Chancen
ja Nein bleiben wir bei a okay bleiben
wir bei a Alex lockt a to ku deine m
ein und das ist richtig ja Wahnsinn
Wahnsinn od ja gut du kennst dich ein
bisschen aus im Thema okay nächste Frage
wie viele songübersetzung hast du
derzeit online
A41 B 43 C 45 oder D
47 B müsste sein B43 je nachdem wie du
zählst gehört die das allererste noch
dazu
ja ja da muss es 43 sein B43 ganz sicher
nein aber Log ein okay wir loggen es
ein und das ist leider nicht richtig
Testbild schade es waren 41 45 es sind
zwei
mehr ja so wie zum
Thema trotzdem eine Frage ist schon
ziemlich
gut jetzt wir richtig
schwierig ver gar nicht warum nicht
weißt okay komm mal dazu also von den
ersten Zeh Alexi bexi Fotos auf Google
Bilder haben wie viele dieser Fotos
keinen greenreen im Hintergrund oh warte
das habe ich sogar mal gegoogelt vor pa
Wochen pass auf okay sind ist es A1 B2
C3 oder
D4 warte ich hatte das gesehen mit dem
kein Green Screen kein Green Screen
Hintergrund also von den Z hat eine
gewisse Zahl Greenscreen Hintergrund
aber eine gewisse eben nicht ein Z D
oder vi ein Z D oder vier boah ich
erinnere mich da war nämlich da da du
hast dich dabei gut vorbereitet du hast
das schon quasi
gegoogelt fotografisches Gedächtnis ja
ja das versuch ich gerade ich habe noch
so diese obere Reihe im Kopf aber ich
bin der Meinung also ich müsste jetzt
ins Blaue raten ich hätte jetzt auch B
gesagt zi B2 fü es dir noch mal vor
Augen
eher drei vielleicht sogar eher nur eins
es können aber auch vier
sein bleiben wir bei einem bei bei bei
zwei nehme
drei
Null nein nein ein Z D oder vi her ja
auch was sagen sie dazu ja mehr kann ich
nicht tun ich habe jetzt schon so
deutliche Mimiken von mir gegeben e klar
sah aus wie verklemmter PS gerade das
macht man mit einem verklemmten da habe
ich lange trainiert das hat mich
verwirrt ich ne ich werde ich wä
trotzdem bei zwei geblieben trotz Deiner
Reaktion
okay ich weiß aber ich könnte ja die
Antwort wissen der ja sagt ja immer ich
weiß es nicht aber der guckt ja auch ja
deswegen gucke ich dir gerade auch mal
so an und
überlege ja komm mach zwei guck Z mach
zwei zwei einloggen ich habe es versucht
ich habe alles getan aber er lässt sich
nicht abbringen es waren vier und bitte
beachten Sie meine Damen und Herren
dieses das die Woll ich gerade sagen das
kann sich ja gerne ändern aber heute
aktuell also gestern haben wir dieses
vorbereitet waren es vier mhm ich hatte
nämlich dieses grüne also die
standardmäßige mit diesem gestreiften
Pulli im Kopf und dann daneben war noch
eins mit dem Hut und ein geteiltes hatte
ich gesehen und alles andere war
eigentlich nur grün deswegen war ich so
zwischen zwei und drei wenn
überhaupt sorry du hast wahrscheinlich
vor zwei Wochen nachgeguckt jetzt
gestern waren es ist schon bisschen
länger her ist wirklich gemein ne Biss
wirklich wir sind total gemeint aber so
also bei uns gibt's und wenn wir
Sternchen genau gibt's immer eigentlich
also auf jeden Fall auf schon bei einer
richtig beantworteten Frage den goldenen
Klick Stern darf ich ih
dirleih der ist richtig schwer das ist
ja echt ja natürlich echt echt oh ich
will mich geehrt ja sieht doch gut aus
oder ja sehr schön der Stern
auch